and you signed a record deal pretty
recently and you said that you wanted to
quote trailblaze a new music style
yeah so what does that mean so um
with like the first uh i guess track
diss track that
uh i did it was it was definitely like
along the lines of just like joking
around in the studio
you know you had one shot one shot
charlie's the tick to your top tick tock
tick tock tick tock tick tock time's
running out 18 till you get clock
we did it in like eight hours we made
like the beat was made
lyrics were written and we sang on it
all within eight hours so
um definitely want to uh continue with
the kind of joking style in
in like the rap um as well as
uh start almost telling stories with the
songs so
it's definitely like a little dickey is
one of the influences
and same with like j cole and chance the
rapper who
do you have your eye on for a next song
well i don't know if the next song will
necessarily be a diss track
or more of like a storytelling song but
um
either way i'm excited to put it out the
first one was about chase hudson right
little huddy
yeah yeah yeah correct what's what's the
relationship like between you guys these
days
after everything i mean
like yeah there were there was a whole i
guess social media blow up about it
recently
i've tried to take a note of just like
you know what
i'll forgive him but i'm not gonna
necessarily forget what he's done
so um yeah it's just like
there's no point of keeping that around
or like
that's why we didn't do still soft as
part two it's just dragging it out
is he someone that you would want to be
a user on the triller app though
i mean i want every creator to feel that
safety and be on an app so of course
did you guys have a conversation after
everything or about the song or anything
uh yeah we had a couple conversations
yeah
they were great they were fun i think
that uh both
uh people kind of like or both of us
learned our lessons in it all and
i mean we're growing up like you said
like i'm 18 years old
so we're still i guess going through the
that that stage and i think
we're past that now and uh we've matured
so it's been i love to hear that yeah
that's good news
um you do have so many followers and
fans and a lot of them are also very
interested in your relationship with
nessa
yes yes you know this are you guys back
together
uh no no we're not back together um just
like kind of like i said with chase like
like i'll forget i've forgiven her for
it we like i wasn't
dating her so it's not really my choice
what she goes and does like that's
totally up to her it's totally fine
right
um i just was in in i guess like uh
still like that fresh stage so i was
probably a little bit jealous i
definitely was jealous
but uh um yeah we're we're friends and
we we hang out
so that's awesome do you see yourself
ever getting past
what happened and getting back together
with her or is it just a no from
oh i'm not going to say like i i know or
yes i think that
right now we're just friends and that's
kind of like how we're doing it
was chase to blame for the breakup as
well not at all
okay what caught what caused the breakup
so we both kind of felt like
um we needed to like grow up we were
like in a very
uh serious relationship but i don't
think that
either of us were like in the right
mindset like i was very very busy with
work all the time
and then as well with her like she was
starting a bunch of new
uh projects and everything like that and
it just got really like
i guess mentally stressful and stuff
like that
you have a lot of eyeballs on you do you
feel pressure at all to be
a good role model um
definitely i think that uh i i
should put myself always in a in a spot
where
i'm setting a good example but at the
same time like i said like i like to be
authentic so
a lot of you know my mess-ups or or
times when i wasn't being 100 myself
uh will like be on the internet or be
talked about
uh but i hope that people can
learn from not like what i've done but
how what i try to do to
keep pushing forward and then give a
message to your fans right now with
everything that's going
on and with the launch of triller and
everything else
uh yeah uh i guess just you know
stay tuned in to what i'm doing try to
follow the journey i'm
absolutely grateful beyond belief for
everything that they've done for me
and that they've given me the
opportunity to be able to do what i do
today
and go and be chief strategy officer at
trailer and
have an energy drink company and so on
and so forth record deal like all that
is because of them so just huge thank
you for them